what i hope to do in this video is get
some practice simplifying some fairly
hairy exponential expressions so let's
get started let's say that i have the
expression 10
times
9 to the t over 2 plus 2
power
times
to the 3
t
and what i want to do is simplify this
as much as possible and and preferably
get it in the form of a
times b
to the t and like always i encourage you
to pause this video and see if you can
do this on your own using exponent
properties your knowledge your deep
knowledge of exponent properties
all right so let's work through this
together and it's really just about
breaking breaking the pieces up so
10 i'll just leave that as 10 for now
there doesn't seem to be much to to do
there but there's all sorts of
interesting things going on here so 9 to
the t over 2 plus 2 so this right over
here i could break this up
using the fact that i'll just write the
properties over here if i have if i have
to the a plus b power this is the same
thing as 9 to the a
times 9
to the b power and over here
i have 9 to the t plus t over 2 plus 2.
so i could rewrite this as
9 to the t over 2 power times
squared times 9 squared all right now
let's move over to 5 to the 3
t
well if i have
a
to the b c
so you could use this as 5 to the 3
times t this is the same thing as a to
the b
and then that to
the c power so i could write this as
this is going to be the same thing as 5
to the third
5 to the third and then that to the t
power and the whole reason i did that is
well this is just going to be a number
and then i have some number to the t
power i want to get as many things just
raised to the t power as possible just
to see if i can simplify this thing
so
this character right over here is going
to be 81 9 squared is 81. 5 to the third
power is 25 times 5 that's 125.
so we're making a good progress and so
the only thing we really have to
simplify this point is 9 to the t over
2. actually let me let me do that over
here 9 to the t
over 2 well that's the same thing that's
the same thing as 9 to the one-half
times t and by this property right over
here that's the same thing as
nine to the one whoops nine
nine to the one half
times or nine to the one half and then
that to the t power so what's 9 to the
one half well that's three so this is
going to be equal to 3 to the t power so
this right over here is 3
to the
3 to the t power so now this is getting
interesting so i have the 10 out front
i have the 10 out front times
3 to the t
actually let me write the 81 first 10
times 81
times 3 to the t so all i did is i just
swapped the order that i'm multiplying
times
125 to the t
125 to the t power
now the 10 times 81 i could just
multiply that out that's going to be 810
and then what's 3 to the t times 125 to
the t
well this is another exponent property
at play here because if i have a times b
to the t power that's a to the t
times b to the t or another way to think
about it if i have a to the t times b to
the t that's the same thing as a times b
to the t power and so over here i have 3
to the t
times 125 to the t so it's going to be
the same thing as 3 times 125 to the t
power
so this part of it
right over here i could rewrite it as
3 times
and i'm going to raise that whole thing
to the t power so i'm in the home
stretch this is going to be 810
times 3 times 125 is
times 300 375
to the
to the t power and that's about as
simplified as we can get and we did
indeed write it in the form that we hope
to write it in that a times b to the t
where if we actually match this form
right over here this right over here
would be our a
and then our b would be the 370 b the b
would be the 375. so anyway i know it
looked a little bit daunting when you
first saw it but if you just keep saying
okay let's just keep applying some
exponent properties here let's see if i
can get multiple things to the t power
and keep breaking it down using these
properties you see that not too many
steps you get to something that's
a lot less hairy